rosenfeld
flaschen rosenfeld
rosenfeld feldenkirchen
das mal ganz deutschland wartet gebannt
auf die letzte diskussion der
spitzenkandidaten und kandidaten der
parteien und der nette sender phoenix
hat uns beide gebot gebeten heute mal
etwas anders zu machen nicht über ein
thema unserer wahl zu reden sondern über
etwas zu sprechen was wir definitiv
nicht beantworten können wo wir
keinerlei ahnung haben wie die ganze
kiste dieser wahlkampf hier ausgehen
wird du zuerst mit deinem geballtem
fachwissen
wer wird gewinnen also ich habe heute
gelernt dass es auf den wahlkreis
pinneberg ankommen weil es nämlich
offenbar so ist das seit der
bundestagswahl
1953 immer die partei die das
direktmandat in pinneberg geholt hat
dann auch den kanzler gestellt hat also
ganz deutschland wird gebannt nach
pinneberg gucken kann ich mich jetzt gar
nicht aus aber du neu hier bist im hohen
norden dann bin ich nicht so ich bin ja
eher die rheinländerin aber mehr
prognose wage ich auch gar nicht weil
das rennen zwischen cdu und spd ist so
knapp es geht um 3 4 prozentpunkte die
den unterschied am ende machen können
und ich habe ein gesundes misstrauen
gegenüber umfragen entwickelt weil wenn
umfragen recht gehabt hätten dann wäre
trampe niemals us präsident geworden und
die briten werden noch heute in der eu
ich muss ja sagen so beknackt weil
belanglos ich den wahlkampf fand weil es
uns so viele nebensächlichkeiten bin so
toll finde ich doch die gesamtsituation
das wirklich bis zum letzten tag nicht
klar ist welche partei wird stärkste
partei welche figur wird bundeskanzler
vielleicht wissen wir es sogar am
wahlabend nicht weil dann erst mal
wochen und monate lang miteinander
sondiert wird und geschaut wird wer
möchte
was glaubst du wer macht seinem sonntag
ich glaube ehrlich gesagt aber es ist
wie gesagt die unseriöse sendung die wir
jeweils zusammen machen werden weil
reines spekulation aber ich glaube dass
armin laschet auf den letzten metern
noch mal aufholt und knapp vor olaf
scholz und der spd liegen wird keine
ahnung warum aber ich halte es für
möglich dieser wahlkampf hat so viele
überraschende wendung gebracht da würde
es mich nicht überraschen wenn lastet so
ein mini
schlussspurt hinlegt und natürlich
trotzdem das schlechteste ergebnis der
union aller zeiten einfahren also das
für denkbar dass er das schlechteste
ergebnis haben auf jeden fall das ist
gesetzt da würde ich kistenweise rotwein
für verwetten ich halte es auch nicht
für ausgeschlossen dass er auf den
letzten metern noch aufholt 40 prozent
sind immer noch unentschieden in diesem
land und wer weiß in der wahlkabine
entdecken sie dann doch vielleicht eher
herz noch mal für die cdu weil sie dann
doch dort mehr kontinuität verordnen als
es ein olaf scholz tun könnte und ich
glaube dass wir ein sehr struktur
konservatives land sind nicht
konservativ im politischen sinne sondern
was gewohnheiten und ja politische
gesetzmäßigkeiten angriff allzu viel
wandel ist glaube ich in diesem land
eigentlich gar nicht gewinnen das haben
ja bevor dieser war diese wahl spannend
wurde fast alle wahlforscher gesagt dass
die union ein weitaus größeres
theoretisches potenzial hat in einem
wahlkampf muss man das natürlich auch
ausschöpfen und da hat vor allem armin
laschet zusammen natürlich mit markus
söder alles mögliche getan um da
so wenig von auszuschöpfen wie möglich
bei der spd ist es theoretische
reservoir viel kleiner da scheint scholz
vieles richtig gemacht zu haben aber
jetzt stellen wir uns das mal vor also
union circa 25 prozent spd circa 25
prozent was passiert ja das ist die
große frage also das besondere an dieser
wahl ist ja nicht nur dass wir
wahrscheinlich zum ersten mal keine
partei mehr haben werden die über 30
prozent kommt alle werden unter 30 sein
und die frage die sich ja jetzt stellt
ist musst du unbedingt stärkste kraft
sein um am ende ins kanzleramt ein 10
oder kann wie es ja in der cdu jetzt
schon im vorauseilenden gehorsam
eingepreist den zweiten platz haben sie
ja quasi eingepreist zu sagen es kommt
darauf an wer am ende eine koalition
zustande bringen und da ist die cdu ja
ganz auf dem jamaica triple christian
lindner hätte sie an ihrer seite und
dann ist eben die frage welches angebot
macht man den grünen dass sie sich
vielleicht gegen eine ampel oder eine
regierung mit zu entscheiden und am ende
mit laschet und lindner nach hause gehen
also erstmal zu diesem argument nur die
stärkste kraft darf auch bundeskanzler
werden war in der geschichte schon also
dann hätte es ein bundeskanzler willy
brandt nie gegeben auch helmut schmidt
nicht meint er hat ja da hatte die spd
sogar weniger stimmen als die union mit
franz josef strauß das muss man sich
schon mal bestellen aber die fdp war ja
damals mit der spd in einer koalition
und hat auch einen wahlkampf gemacht
indem es die ansage gab es soll sozial
überall seien deshalb finde ich auch
wenn sich ein bündnis findet das in
irgendeiner form ein gesellschaftliches
anliegen hat wo es nicht nur darum geht
ok hier darf einer bundeskanzler werden
und hier dürfen ein paar leute
ministerinnen und minister werden
sondern wenn man tatsächlich
glaubhaft darlegen kann hier es eine
vorstellung vom gesellschaft die uns
verbindet eine vision fürs land dieser
projekt gedanke einer koalition dann
finde ich spielt es überhaupt keine
rolle wer da ursprünglich stärkste kraft
war weil das wäre für mich überzeugen ob
das eine ampel regierung sein kann oder
eine jamaika regierung da habe ich
allerdings doch große zweifel weil ich
glaube da sind
koalitionsverhandlungen tatsächlich nur
ganz wilde tarifverhandlungen und es
gibt mehr trennendes als gemeinsames
und wo siehst du dann das gemein also
wäre für dich schwarz grünen die
koalition gewesen die das gemeinsam von
openscape könnte man wenn man es denn
möchte eine gemeinsame erzählung
stricken ein
gesellschaftliches anliegen und
natürlich aus einem linksbündnis weißt
du bist du bist der sohn erzogen mensch
aber lasst uns doch noch manchen ist
wohl
gegen bares wortes über schwarz-grün
gerade gesprochen und das klingt heute
total absurd ein zweierbündnis aus cdu
und grünen ein bündnis wo wir mal
gedacht haben das sind würde sogar von
den grünen angeführt werden können das
ist nur ein paar monate her jetzt sind
wir ganz woanders unterwegs annalena
baerbock die bei euch auch schon mal ich
glaube er war zwar eine wie keine
spiegel kann man mal was ihr das also
jubelarien auf annalena baerbock schon
als künftige kanzlerin jetzt ist sie
raus aus dem rennen ich würde mich auch
so weit vorwagen zu sagen das kanzleramt
ist passé für die grünen also es werden
entweder wird es olaf scholz oder armin
laschet markus glaub so deutschland ist
reif für einen mann im kanzleramt
dual screen ist sie am tisch sagt welche
als feminist würde ganz großzügig sagen
es soll noch mal einer die chance
bekommen und das ist schon in ordnung
würde ich sagen also ich glaube dass für
viele menschen unter 40 vor allem frauen
unter 40 sie wirklich eine ganz große
hoffnung mit annalena baerbock verbunden
haben dass trotz der ganzen
idiotischen patzer die sie in diesem
wahlkampf hingelegt hat sie für viele
frauen in diesem land nach wie vor ein
rollenmodell ist dies gut finden dass
sie sich dort das zugetraut hat die ihr
auch verzeihen das was sie versemmelt
hat also ich glaube da wird etwas von
bleiben aber sie wird diesmal nicht
bundeskanzlerin
da bin ich auch ziemlich überzeugt von
und dann hätte ein mann nochmal eine
chance glaubst du eigentlich wir sind
hier schon ein bisschen nostalgisch und
gucken auf diesen wahlkampf zurück
glaubst du dass sie härter angegangen
worden ist als ihre männlichen kollegen
ich glaube das nicht das ist ein weit
verbreitetes narrativ gerade von
frauen die mitglied bei den grünen sind
in führender position oder nicht wird es
dieser tage immer wieder bemüht aber
wenn ich mir mal angucken wie in diesem
wahlkampf alleine mit armin laschet um
gehören diese dann mit laschet
umgegangen ist ein skandal oder
absolut und meine auch im netz armin
laschet hat ähnlich wie annalena
baerbock sehr viel anders gegeben
unnötigen anlass dass man ihn
kritisieren kann trotzdem war das maß
der himmel auch der aggression gegen
armin laschet ich meine man kann ihn
vieles vorwerfen aber ist ja irgendwie
kein mensch der politiker abgebaut also
diese aggressionen die man da zum teil
erlebt gegen ihn die die wundern mich
sehr und deshalb dass die kritik an
annalena baerbock damit zu tun hat dass
sie eine frau ist das glaube ich kein
bisschen was glaubst du welche partei in
diesem wahlkampf am stärksten unter
ihren möglichkeiten geblieben ist die
union oder die grünen also die union hat
keine möglichkeiten und das ist einfach
in diesem wahlkampf jetzt offenbar
geworden die union ist zu einer partei
ohne eigenschaften geworden
die so verwässert in allem ist dass sie
einen kandidaten mit kontur gebraucht
hätte ich glaube es wäre schöner gewesen
also ich glaube die union hat sich für
den falschen kandidaten entschieden und
das haben die grünen auch getan und die
grünen sind für mich die partei die
jetzt am krassesten unter ihren
möglichkeiten geblieben ist weil sie
sind ja schon die verteidigung momenten
am ende 15 prozent haben dann ist das
fast doppelt so viel wie beim letzten
mal das überzeugt sichtlich weil der
maßstab ist ja nicht was war beim
letzten mal sondern wo wollte man hin
und die grünen gehören zu denen die
sagen sie sind zukunftspartei und
zukunft wird aus mut gemacht also gucken
wir doch nicht nach hinten was war
sondern nach vorne was sein sollte und
das war das kanzleramt
und die grünen lagen bei 30 prozent die
lagen sogar mal vor der union und sie
hatten ja vor allem ein momentum was
keine andere partei hatte sie hatten
frei disco future das war ein kinder und
jugendliche die das grünen thema nehme
ich den klimawandel in die wohnzimmer
ihrer eltern getragen haben ins
bewusstsein von vätern und müttern die
sich auch aus dem bürger ins visier
wow
lasst mich ernst bleiben die sich also
im bürgerlichen milieu haben festsetzen
können der verdienst von habeck und
bernburg ist gewesen dass sie auch
diesen öko dunkel aus der partei
getrieben haben und sich geöffnet haben
und jetzt siehst du auf den letzten
metern wo es nicht läuft fällt berbalk
inso alte muster zurück also jetzt ist
es wieder linke sozialpolitik die sie zu
ihrem thema macht verbots lust kommt
wieder also durch verbote entstehen
innovationen das sind die grünen risi
mal waren und wir sie eigentlich keiner
haben linke sozialpolitik stand
allerdings die ganze zeit schon im
programm wurde nur nicht so thematisiert
ich glaube ja dass
anders als du es gesagt hast die union
mit markus söder nicht erfolgreicher
gewesen wäre also erstens finde ich
hatte einen riesengroßen anteil daran
dass die kandidatur von armin laschet
jetzt nicht so der mega erfolg war weil
er davon act am anfang quasi schon mal
so öffentlich filetiert hat da blieb nur
noch ein beruf der laschet übrig ich
glaube aber auch dass die probleme der
union nach 16 jahren merkel programm
losigkeit
einfach ermüdung im regierungshandeln
dass die so groß sind dass auch markus
söder hier keinen großen anderen
wahlkampf hingelegt hätte ich glaube
sogar dass ich viele von ihm
ja so abgeschreckt eingeschüchtert
gefühlt hätten also das wäre ganz andere
probleme gewesen die wählerinnen und
wähler mit kandidaten söder gehabt haben
als diese vor laschet haben bei ihm ist
eher das problem dass er nicht ganz
ernst genommen wird ich glaube jeder
wäre zu ernst genommen
laschet wird auf jeden fall nach der
wahl 18 uhr die ersten probleme mit
söder weiter haben und noch in viel
massiver wenn du dir an guckst markus
blume hat schon also der söders
generalsekretär hat ja schon gesagt es
muss fehler aufarbeitung gemacht werden
und ich bin mir auch nicht so sicher
selbst wenn laschet knapp vorne liegt ob
die csu ruhe geben wird und ob sie in
ruhe geben wird sie nicht aber für armin
laschet ist natürlich entscheidend hat
er nach dem wahlergebnis einen
berechtigten anspruch darauf
bundeskanzler zu werden dann ist von der
kritik die die sonst kommen würde
sicherlich erstmal nicht auf dem tisch
davon hat auch angela merkel profitiert
als sie erst mal kanzlerin war
war das ein anderes spiel für sie wenn
er diesen anspruch nicht hat ist eine
politische karriere wohl auch vorbei
oder das sehe ich genauso und der
phantomschmerz ab montag dass kein
wahlkampf mehr ist der wird uns etwas
genommen werden dadurch dass markus
söder so weiter machen sind wir es im
wahlkampf getan hat nämlich frontal
gegen lasche so und in einer woche
treffen uns wieder und reden darüber was
wir heute für ein unsinn prognostiziert
haben in ordnung
[Musik]